let's jump into some phone calls at 6 1
7 8 3 0 47 50 let's start with our
caller from the 3 6 0 area code caller
what's your name and where are you
calling from David uh Terrence you know
it sounds like you've got bad reception
didn't get your name didn't get where
you were calling from it anyway we could
try once more let's see if we can get a
working signal from you sorry about that
my name is jeremy gloucester the firm at
washington alright we could barely hear
you let's give one shot at hearing what
your question is but if we can't get
better service we're gonna have to move
on I think he said Jeremy right yeah
yeah okay what's on her mind Jeremy so I
guess Michael so I was just thinking
about the you know the Kathy Griffin
photo yeah that she released with the
head of Donald Trump and Trump released
a tweet yesterday saying that a you know
it affected all of his children
including his 11 old son Barron and I
was thinking I hope you're back a couple
months ago but uh Rosie O'Donnell was
making looks about Baron being autistic
everything and he didn't say it one one
word and so I just thought that it was
interesting I guess but uh he only cared
about you know he only made a public
statement about Baron and how things
were affecting him when it was like a
direct attack on him yeah that's
interesting right well nobody actually
goes after Baron and from silent about
how Baron is impacted by that now all of
a sudden someone does something that
Trump doesn't like about him and the
concern all of a sudden is his 11 year
old son Baron I didn't think about that
I mean honestly Jeremy I didn't talk
about that this story because I was
thinking Kathy Griffin held up a doll
effectively the head of a doll and Trump
is leaving the Paris climate Accord it
just seems so inconsequential in context
but that you're making a good point I
appreciate you doing it yeah no I don't
anyone's really thought about it so I
just wanted to get your guys's opinion
on it yeah yeah no that's interesting
and I think I mean it just it goes to
Trump self-centeredness right I mean
when it's convenient he's sort of
putting his son out there is this is why
it's all so bad but when it's actually
about his son Trump silent on yeah it's
like it's affecting him so negatively
because now he has to go out there and
console his son because he's so upset
right as if anyone believes that that's
what Trump is spending his time doing
all right thanks Jeremy appreciate the
call yeah no problem thank you guys all
right take care